this [ __ ]
white maga rap [ __ ] that's popping right
now
it's [ __ ]
terrible in my opinion it's weird right
so like
so
my homie burton um
was a who's absolute dog [ __ ]
well i i can't i can't join them with
that because just i'm just i'm i can
though yeah yeah i can't he's an
atrocious
atrocious artist anyway continue no no
that's that's fine i i can't join in
only because the same thing i i you know
i'm a friend man like
i was happy to see his numbers go up you
know what i'm saying i saw his numbers
because you would work with that guy
like back in the day before he was going
to work with him and i know him as a
like not know him as a person like we're
boys but like norman's like backs i i
just you know if i meet somebody and i
get along with him i get a lot of them
you know
so i saw what he was doing and i was
happy to see his numbers going up
doing what he's doing
and i like and i'm using him only as an
example he's he's the type of god bird
man stop that [ __ ] he's the type of
god it'd be like be happy i'm talking
about him on here like oh [ __ ] i'm about
to get you know but now this is real
[ __ ] like i like this kid like like not
kid like i like this guy like he's a
good guy
and i'm happy his numbers are growing
but the thing is man
and this is not just him yeah it's just
i don't know man i'm so disappointed in
the human race
with all this [ __ ] [ __ ] man and i
don't want to say trump [ __ ] to get
people mad at me like oh ritz is all
left liberal it's like no
just understandable you know what i'm
saying i'm just i understand like if you
were to sit here and be like yo
i love the mag of white boy rap
you're my friend so i'm not gonna hate
you right right
you know what i'm saying i just wish
more people would develop that mindset
of just being a little bit more
understanding but yeah as far as rap
goes what you're asking and i know
you're see this bootleg kev he's
addicted he'll ask you these questions
to get the real out of you and he's he's
that's all he's sitting there waiting on
yeah but you don't quit being a [ __ ]
and answer the question so
yes
i [ __ ] hate
the [ __ ] way the state of the
country's in with all this [ __ ] and
i hate that it's in hip-hop yo man this
is black music this is black music man
period
this is what the [ __ ] has been a lot of
[ __ ] has been going down and and
everybody on that other side is tripping
and it's been [ __ ] up for a long time
y'all are tripping to use rap music as a
quote as a as a sales pitch for this
[ __ ] music y'all are [ __ ]
tripping yeah my thing is that's what
i'm saying real quick my bad care
because a lot of people might eat me up
over that and i don't have like a i
don't want to piss anybody off but this
is hip-hop
you know what i'm saying and you know
what
what that side stands for
for the most part
and not that everybody and i'm
understandable doesn't it and i'm open
to independent thinkers i'm open to all
that i'm just saying no but don't let's
not use rap music i can't care what you
feel like in regular society that's fine
but rap music
it's black music and when you're using
your music to [ __ ] on black lives matter
and
the push and the push blue lives matter
and police i'm like bro
someone get these people to [ __ ] up out
of here like man this is rap music
that's it i'm just a hipaa i'll just
leave it as simple as that i'm hip-hop
bro and that [ __ ] ain't cool
but
to my friends it's low-hanging fruit for
these [ __ ] because they get
such easy numbers because there's all
these people who at the same time though
let's be honest it's not their [ __ ]
fault there's a whole society here
that's allowed it's consuming the music
to have them yeah i mean obviously it's
working for someone let's not like like
let me not [ __ ] on them like they're
terrible human beings there's a host
they're just terrible rappers
there's a whole society cat that
i don't disagree obviously there's an
entire part there's they have fans i
know you don't disagree i'm just saying
like that's how weird it is now right
you know it's strange bro and you know
it's going to be even more shrines a
year from now kev's got one of them on
there and he's on this show right now
i'm sitting he's like dude
for real i feel you right now dude cause
like never